hi guys it's me quinn and as always if
you appreciate my content consider
hitting the like button it's the only
way the youtube algorithm really notices
me
recently
i had the pleasure of reading what is
likely the most terrifying science
fiction book series i've ever read
i've always enjoyed scary stories as a
kid i read anthologies like goosebumps
or scary stories to tell in the dark
but i didn't know true fear until i
encountered the works of stephen king
and h.p lovecraft in my teenage years
lovecraft's work opened up such
terrifying vistas of thought
that i would while reading them become
transfixed and filled with ultimate
existential dread
the cosmic terrors he wrote about in his
story struck me as somehow realer than
the monsters and ghost of goosebumps and
that is probably because lovecraft in
truth being the flawed man he was was
expressing a very simple fear
the fear of the unknown
and what is more unknown than the
blackness of space
i must admit that not since my early
teenage years have i felt such poignant
terror while reading as i did when first
encountering the work of lovecraft
that is until i read the remembrance of
earth's past trilogy
there are three books in this series the
three-body problem the dark forest and
death sinned
there is also an additional book not
written by sixteen law himself called
redemption of time
the first book in the series the
three-body problem starts off as a
mystery
as the story unfolds it starts to feel
as though we are reading the unfolding
of some grand conspiracy
a conspiracy written into the fabric of
the universe itself
early on in the story you find out that
scientists around the world have been
killing themselves
a note left behind by one of the late
scientists yandong ominously adds to the
mysteries saying only all the evidence
points to a single conclusion
physics has never existed and will never
exist
i know what i'm doing is irresponsible
but i have no choice
we base so much of our own perception of
what we consider to be reality on what
we can observe
we look upon the universe and
extrapolate from that point
but what if we will never be able to
know the truth about the universe what
if the universal constants are not
constant what if the laws of physics are
not laws
what if reality isn't real
before we get any further into the video
i have to give a spoiler warning
if you have not read this series i
highly recommend you stop this video and
do so
if you've read the series or just don't
care about spoilers then continue forth
now we won't be getting into all of the
details of this series but i will be
giving context on why exactly i think
it's so unnerving
ultimately the secret of the first book
is this
we are not alone in the universe
we are not alone in the milky way just
four light years from our own solar
system
lives another species
they have heard the call of earth from
the vacuum of space
and because their own world is unstable
in a constant state of varying extremes
due to the three-sun structure of their
solar system
they have chosen earth as their new home
they intend to exterminate the human
race
like bugs
though their technology is great due to
the great distance of space it will take
the aliens named the tricelerians 400
years to arrive on earth but in the
meantime through technology involving
quantum entanglement they were able to
stifle the progress of human scientific
development
scientific theories based on humanity's
current understanding of physics were
rendered useless
the tricelerians had led humankind into
a trap
and the trap had snapped closed
leaving humanity as a helpless victim
only capable of waiting until the
predator arrived to claim its prey
everything that humankind did was
monitored in real time by the
tricelerians as their fleet made its way
from their home world to the world of
earth
nothing could be concealed from them
save the thoughts hidden away within the
individual human minds
for a while the world struggles to
adjust attempting to find solutions it
was briefly considered that a portion of
the human species might be sent off into
the vacuum of space on generational
ships
escapism would have had three potential
goals
the first option would be finding a new
world among the stars where humanity
could survive
this would have been the most ideal
option
the next option would be a starship
civilization its citizens aboard an
eternal voyage
the third option would have been for
humanity to take temporary refuge among
the stars they would hope to return
after trisolaris had settled in the
solar system and attempt to co-exist
with the aliens
but escapism could never truly happen
not because humanity's technology
couldn't potentially reach the level
sufficient enough to allow it but
because human nature would prevent it
from ever getting off the ground
it is simply a matter of who is allowed
to leave
and who is condemned to face the wrath
of the tricelerians on earth
no matter who got to leave whether they
be elite or poor
humankind's fundamental value system
would ultimately collapse
for the idea of equality would be
utterly shattered
human rights and equality have deep
roots inequality of survival is the
worst sort of inequality and the people
and countries left behind will never
just sit and wait for death while others
have a way out there will be
increasingly extreme confrontations
between the two sides until there's
world chaos and then no one goes
the united nations realizing this simple
fact overwhelmingly voted to ban
escapism
instead choosing to focus on what they
could do from earth to thwart the
tricelerians including the formation of
a space force
even with everything the world leaders
attempted in order to maintain stability
eventually society did collapse in an
apocalyptic testing event known as the
great ravine
during the great ravine the space force
was brought to the brink of collapse
inflation skyrocketed credit systems
unraveled it started with the slow
economic transformation that often
accompanied wartime the standard of
living declined and the political
climate grew more and more intense
but instead of it just being one or a
few countries it was the entire earth
society was on edge and if you said
something wrong they would say your eto
or a traitor to humanity
so nobody felt safe and film and
television from the golden age began to
be restricted and then was banned
worldwide but eventually things got even
worse
humanity began to starve
climate change had already been greatly
accelerated with the coming of the
tricelerian crisis humanity grew
pessimistic
even if they saved the earth made it
into eden come again it would be an eden
for the tricelerians not them
only the space force was given thought
and its continued development only
further polluted the earth
so climate change accelerated the
environment changed the temperature
raised forest and plains became desert
the process of desertification had not
been subtle or gradual
the green of the earth had eroded
simultaneously like a damp towel left
out to dry in the sun
food production halted for there was no
grain being grown
and for the next 50 years the planet was
famished
the population of the earth decreased by
five billion during those years all
while the triceleran fleet marched on
steadily
one of the most intriguing things about
these books
mainly the second book the dark forest
is how they show the effect that the
imminent tricelerin invasion has on
humanity before the aliens even arrive
within the solar system
initially many people denied that the
invasion was truly real
once the truth became widely accepted a
sense of dread crept over all mankind
religions had to change to make way for
the existence of extraterrestrials
humanity could no longer hide behind the
comforting fantasy of our own uniqueness
we were not unique we were one of the
potentially endless civilizations out
there in the
dark the scariest part of this book
series in my opinion is also in the
second book the dark forest
in this book we begin to unravel the
truth about the state of life in the
universe
the book calls us to consider cosmic
sociology
if you supposed that a vast amount of
civilizations were distributed
throughout the universe based on the
number of detectable stars
those civilizations would make up the
body of cosmic sociology
cosmic sociology is based on two axioms
first
survival is the primary need of
civilization
second civilization continuously grows
and expands but the total number of
matter in the universe remains constant
these two axioms are all that is needed
to extrapolate the ultimate horrifying
truth about cosmic society
it is a secret that the tricelerians
themselves knew and called the most
important secret in the universe
it was the secret that the universe
itself
was a dark forest
the universe is a dark forest
every civilization an armed hunter
stalking through the trees like a ghost
gently pushing aside branches that block
the path and trying to tread without
sound even breathing is done with care
the hunter has to be careful because
everywhere in the forest are stealthy
hunters like him
if he finds other life
another hunter an angel or demon a
delicate infant or tottering old man a
fairy or demigod
there is only one thing he can do
open fire and eliminate them
in this forest hell is other people an
eternal threat that any life that
exposes its own existence will be
swiftly wiped out
this is the picture of cosmic
civilization
it's the explanation for the fermi
paradox
the famous fermi paradox of course
brings up the quandary if based on what
we know about the universe it should be
full of life
then where is said life
why is the universe seemingly silent
this series provides a single terrifying
answer
we don't see them
because they are hiding
like all life on earth
life in the universe must compete to
survive
it is a cruel fact about the nature of
life itself
if the location of a world is revealed
it is marked in a way
a metaphorical spotlight is shown upon
it a blinking sign stating there is
intelligent life here destroy it before
it destroys you
eventually the mark will be noticed
it is only a matter of time
it doesn't matter what motivated someone
to leave the mark
what's important is that the dead hand
has stretched the nerves of the dark
force to the breaking point
and it's the most sensitive nerve that's
most liable to make a move
suppose there are a million hunters in
the forest
the number of civilizations on the
billions upon billions of stars in the
milky way could be thousands of times
that perhaps nine hundred thousand of
them will disregard the marking of the
remaining 100 000 maybe 99 000 of them
will probe the location
and after confirming that it has no life
disregarded
but one of the remaining ten thousand
hunters will surely make the choice to
fire on that position
because for civilizations at a certain
level of technological development
attacking may be safer and less of a
hassle than probing
if there's really nothing at that
location then there's no loss
the idea that the universe could be a
dark forest strikes fear into my very
core
humans have always seemed to be
fascinated with the idea of
extraterrestrial life
making contact
for more than a hundred years we have
blasted the sky with signals sending
pieces of our world out unto the cosmos
in the form of waves
never thinking about exactly who might
be listening
though humans have revealed themselves
to the tricelerics who only wanted to
colonize the earth for themselves
there were things far worse and far more
powerful than the tricelerins
ancient civilizations were shielded in
the dark and armed with the power to rip
apart dimensions
another fascinating and also quite
troubling concept sixth and low forces
us to consider in his books
is the potential effect that life has
had upon the universe itself
without life the earth would be a
different plant
there would be no oceans no rivers
the entire surface of the planet would
be as dry as mars
life is not some tiny shell clinging to
the surface of the world
fragile waiting to be snuffed out in an
instant
life with the aid of time is powerful
enough to move mountains
and without life
it is very possible that by what we now
consider to be the modern era
liquid water would not exist on planet
earth
plants animals and bacteria all have had
important roles in the present
composition of our atmosphere without
life the atmosphere would be very
different
it's possible that such an atmosphere
would not be able to shield the surface
of the earth against solar winds and
ultraviolet rays
and the oceans would evaporate soon
greenhouse effects would turn the
earth's atmosphere into a copy of
venuses and then water vapor would be
lost to space over time
after several billion years the earth
would be dry
the earth that we and all other life on
this planet inhabit is ultimately a home
constructed by life for itself if we
take this idea and apply it to the
universe itself then this thought occurs
if life has had such a drastic effect on
the earth
then what effect has life as a whole had
on the universe itself
and what would the universe look like
without life
if life was exceedingly rare in the
universe its impact on the evolution of
the cosmos could be ignored
but if the universe was in fact
teeming with life as the famous drake
equation suggests
then a terrifying question arises
how much has the universe from its
original state been altered by life
is the nature that we experience
natural at all
a terrifying revelation comes near the
end of the final book in the series
death sinned
the universe had once been 10
dimensional
a state of perfection
but due to the destructive nature of
life itself those dimensions have
collapsed
and the universe will continue to
collapse until only a single dimension
remained
countless ancient civilizations
potentially possessed the capability of
initiating dimension collapses in parts
of the universe
it was one of the methods that hunters
in the dark forest used to eliminate
other intelligent species
the problem was that once a dimension
strike occurred
it never ended
the universe itself
was dying
drying up in patchwork formation as the
earth had done during the great ravine
the endless cosmic darkness that we saw
as the universe today had been the
result of the endless battles of the
dark forest
and we as humans would never know the
true beauty and perfection of the
original cosmos
aside from pure existential dread this
series has so many great science fiction
ideas that i just love such as the idea
of cryogenics the philosophy behind
people being willing to freeze
themselves in the present in order to
wake up in the future is based on a very
human but often not true assumption
that the future will somehow be better
than now
many of the characters throughout this
book series experience being frozen and
unthawed in a different era
i find it fascinating to read about how
someone from a specific era interacts
with the world and the people of a new
era
this idea is also at the heart of one of
my all-time favorite science fiction
shows the light-hearted animation show
futurama whose main character after
being frozen for a thousand years wakes
up in the year 3000 and has to deal with
the fact that not only is he living in a
world completely alien to him but also
everyone that he's ever known is dead
six and lo's use of the concept of this
helped to illustrate the idea that
humans are humans even when coming from
a different era
sixth inlaw throughout this series also
explores the concept of the long view of
history he explores how certain events
and figures throughout human history
evolve in the way they are perceived by
humanity men become gods gods become
devils heroes become villains and vice
versa we see this mainly with the
characters luogi and changzin as their
stories progress throughout the
centuries
and also the inhabitants of the ships
blue space and gravity
who at certain point in history
considered to be the enemies of all
mankind and at other points take on near
mythic proportions in the mind of some
humans all due to the varying
perspectives created by the different
vantage points of time
on the whole humanity seems to possess
fleeting short-term memories and ideas
that aren't constantly reinforced
instantly fade away in the midst of time
this is the reason that humanity seems
to constantly repeat its old mistakes
we as a species simply forget
some would say that sixth in lewis
trilogy is a quite pessimistic one and i
have to agree to an extent
sixteen look does seem to present a
pretty pessimistic view of human nature
as a whole though certain individuals
can sometimes come up with solutions
that could potentially help the human
entity as a whole for some reason resist
it is easy to see the tricelerin crisis
in particular as a metaphor for climate
change destruction is imminent perhaps
distant but certain and it's likely that
modern humans won't be affected nearly
as much as the generations to come after
can humankind come together to stop this
crisis
and ensure the survival of its future
generations
one of the most interesting parts of the
series is when we get to see how the
various governments cooperate when it
comes to dealing with the crisis in the
beginning
at some point the book mentions that
there was a push for socialized
technology
which would have given the human race as
a whole a greatly increased chance of
survival
the major world powers flat out rejected
this notion because they believed it
would weaken them
not even the sure threat of alien
annihilation was enough to force the
world to cooperate
the us government said that no form of
socialized technology was realistic that
it was a naive idea and that under the
present circumstances u.s national
security was a priority second only to
planetary defense
i would say that humankind as a whole is
depicted as being rather selfish in this
series and many times we see how the
species cannibalizes itself
humanity is often its own greatest
hindrance
the books are not all pessimism however
the final book in the series that sin
does in fact end with certain optimistic
undertones by highlighting the endurance
of the human race and its spirit
sixth and look combines philosophy
science and pure horror to create what
is honestly one of the best science
fiction book series i've ever read
the series is endlessly bold and
unpredictable
even the spoilers i've mentioned in this
video barely begin to get to the place
where these books eventually go
the third book death sin gets more into
the idea of the interdimensionality of
the universe which is endlessly
intriguing and quite trippy actually
the series feels boundless in a way that
a lot of other books just don't the
questions about humanity about the
universe that are brought up in this
series are questions that i've been
pondering since i read it a few months
ago
the books aren't scary in the
traditional sense but the
it explores are chilling to the bone
the remembrance of earth's past is
science fiction at its best and i hope
to cover more of the series and explore
some of its other concepts in future
videos
thanks so much for watching guys
[Music]
you